No matter what you're doing, if you can't beat the point of contact
Farrer Prefecture will bloom your Otherwise, Soul Eater won't come out But
if you're fighting,
hey, you should protect the village too I can't fight because I'm incompetent  Which one is the download? If
you don't end the wave, the monsters won't know, and you
can't protect the village either.
Throw it away,
ah, ah
, I know it doesn't have to be told by you,
so knock down the skeleton and run on the bases Oh, you knocked it down a while ago, but it's thunder, isn't it
?  What attribute is Paro Hey, I don't have a turn
If a soul eater doesn't appear Is
there any other way than defeating
it
?
It's around
yeah yeah yeah
Local key to attack point
[music] See
what they gave me
.